Southeast Asia is often overshadowed by Europe,
the Middle East, and East Asia’s major powers,
but the region is of great importance to the
United States.
Today, Southeast Asia is poised to become
a driver of global economic growth, which
is crucial at a time when China is facing
growing economic headwinds.
But Southeast Asia also faces myriad security
challenges: from Chinese encroachment in the
South China Sea, to the scourge of terrorism
and insurgency, to non-traditional security
threats like natural disasters and transnational
crime.
These challenges, along with limited political
freedom in a number of countries, could prevent
the region from reaching its full potential.
To ensure that it does, the United States
should deepen engagement in the region to
dissuade China from future destabilizing behavior,
to counter terrorism and insurgency, to promote
free market principles, and
to encourage more resilient and more accountable
governance.
In doing so, the United States can shape a
Southeast Asia that is open, peaceful, and
prosperous — and over the longer-term, freer as well —
a good result for Americans and Southeast Asians alike.
What do you think about US/Southeast Asian relations? Let us know in your comments.
Also let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.